What do desalination membranes methane catalysts safer refrigerants
lithium recovery PFAS cleanup clean-air catalysts and low-carbon
cement have in common
Weirdly the same atomic blind spot
The materials bottleneck is not climate-specific
It is coordination-specific
Universal machine-learning potentials learn tidy bulk crystals where
atoms have lots of regular neighbors
But useful chemistry happens at pores surfaces vacancies
and transition states—where atoms have fewer neighbors
Right there these models can soften the energy
landscape by 15 to 60 percent
That is not harmless noise
A softened barrier can make the wrong membrane
look selective the wrong catalyst look fast or
an unmakeable cement phase look stable
Across millions of candidates tiny systematic errors flip
rankings—and experiments chase false winners
The stakes are huge water scarcity affects roughly
two billion people
Air pollution kills millions every year
Methane drives about 30 percent of current warming
Clean-energy mineral demand could rise four to six-fold
by 2040
And cement alone produces roughly 2.8 gigatonnes
of carbon dioxide annually
Lupine’s response starts with the useful part the
error has a shape
Three measured observables anchor an environment error field
Bulk coordination is fixed at zero error and
a constrained curve predicts corrections for under-coordinated environments
the field never directly saw
Add that field at runtime and simulations follow
corrected energies and analytic forces—still about one hundred
thousand times faster than quantum chemistry
In blind tests across 36 model-material pairs predicted
corrections correlated at zero point nine oh six
Then 77 build-locked Lean 4 theorems mark what
is supported out of domain or synthesis-dependent
So this is bigger than carbon
One correction-and-verification layer can improve discovery across water
air methane refrigerants minerals PFAS and cement
Measure the error
Correct the physics
Prove the boundary
Then send experiments the candidates actually worth making